you can learn from anyone anywhere and
you can get great talented courses and
teachers to come into your classroom in
effect even if they live across the
world I'm Katherine main keyboard with
recent TV I'm speaking with Michael horn
who's the co-founder of the Clayton
Christensen Institute and the author of
a new book called blended thanks for
being with me Mike thanks for having me
school is really boring for a lot of
kids can you describe what what you
advocate sort of at the Clayton Rose
Institute and in your book for for
fixing that yeah I think one of the big
reasons that school is so boring quite
frankly is that we all have different
learning needs at different times
different things turn us on and with the
opportunity of online learning coming on
well we talked about is shifting from
this factory model system to
student-centered one that personalizes
for each and every child let's start
with the kid who really can't follow
what's going on in class who is you know
being given Shakespeare what what do you
want to see schools do with that kid
yeah so that kid who's struggling
doesn't need to be seeing an advanced
text way beyond his his or her reading
level there's great software like Lexia
learning for example that's out there
put him in a blended learning
environment where for a station he's
going to be doing Lexia learning really
learning the fundamentals of reading and
then move into small group instruction
with the teacher with maybe others at
his level or maybe a diverse array of
students because you want a more rich
conversation around a text another thing
you can use is there's lots of software
out there that will take a very
complicated text and bring it down in a
reading level so that you can still have
a conversation around the same material
throughout a classroom but you can read
at your different level is there any
point to kind of sending kids to a
school building to sit in front of a
computer my my sense is and the data
seems to show they need a blended
environment meaning the academics may be
online to tailor it for their needs but
that real support and custodial safe
environment where they can have teachers
to be there as mentors and quite frankly
to have other kids there as friends
because you know kids it turns out like
to have fun with their friends and
that's a really important part of
schooling that we don't talk about a lot
one thing that strikes me about blended
learning is
that it helps avoid some of the negative
peer pressure both around excelling and
around falling short yeah absolutely so
I think what you see in blended learning
environments is that as opposed to a
traditional environment where someone
looks like the slow kid or maybe it's
cool to actually not be smart in a
blended environment when you're working
in online curriculum or with other peers
that are at your same level you have
this anonymity that really allows you to
excel and it becomes sort of a game
based environment so are you willing to
stake the claim that blended learning
reduces wedgies okay I still to be
determined but I hope I'm hopeful okay
so now talk to me about the kid on the
other you know a kid who's smart at a
school that's good at handling smart
students but but sort of cookie cutters
that kid you know how does that work the
reality with online learning is you can
learn from anyone anywhere and you can
get great talented courses and teachers
to come into your classroom in effect
even if they live across the world to
the extent that we're letting kids
personalize their learning do we wind up
with every second grade boy in America
doing like a six month unit on dinosaurs
and you know not learning anything else
my gut is that a second grader a lot
less choice in what that looks like by
the time you gave it in high school I
think you want to see a lot more choice
how do we do with credentialing in that
environment how do we say this kid is
ready for their Auto Body apprenticeship
and this kid is ready for Harvard how do
we signal that to other place yeah this
gonna be the tricky thing quite frankly
as this revolution sort of continues to
play itself out is how signaling and
credentialing changes because before you
had a stamp that you went to a certain
school and people didn't know what that
really meant but they just said well
like other smart people also went there
so you're probably good enough all hi
are you if a state tries to build
assessments for every possible subject
that is under the Sun good luck it's
insane so I would I think what we like
to see is a lot of organic from industry
from other third-party providers start
to come in
I think it'll actually start at the
higher ed and first with employers
coming together to create a lot of these
assessments then it'll start to trickle
down over time
so just to wrap up why don't you give me
your quick list of the policies that are
in your way
yeah so as you've written I I know we
want to wipe out all these regulations
that constrain how people accomplish
tasks so the assumption that there's one
teacher too many students as opposed to
team teaching or anything that says like
this is the process you have to follow
and the resources you have to use is a
regulation that I think is a bad one
okay thank you very much I know you
speaking with us